et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Claude malure bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité sénateur de l'Allier
président du groupe les indépendants au
Sénat nombre d'horizons le parti
d'Édouard Philippe en est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice don du groupe
Ebra les journaux régionaux de l'Est de
la France bonjour Fabrice bonjour Oriane
bonjour Claude mallery on va parler de
l'Ukraine dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est la réforme des
retraites Elisabeth borne qui a donc
annoncé des modifications des
infléchissements pour répondre aux
demandes des républicains avec notamment
un départ avancé à 63 ans pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21
ans a-t-elle eu raison selon vous
ce que je constate c'est que petit à
petit la réforme va coûter plus cher que
les économies qui sont annoncées donc
écoutez elle est dans une situation très
particulière la dernière fois que qui a
une réforme des retraites celle de
Sarkozy Fillon
il y avait exactement la même situation
la car la situation c'est tout
simplement que
lorsque Mitterrand
décide en 80 de la retraite de 60 ans
alors que c'est absolument impossible à
partir de ce moment-là tous les
gouvernements successifs regardent la
réforme des retraites fera tomber 4
gouvernements de suite donc c'était bien
prévu c'était pas possible c'était une
une arnaque et maintenant les
gouvernements successifs la paie et
c'est eux qui sont un populaire alors
que évidemment cette décision aurait dû
être à l'époque
condamné parce que impossible donc la
différence aujourd'hui c'est que avec
les gouvernements précédents qui avaient
des majorités il y avait un million de
personnes dans la rue à chaque fois et
puis la retraite finissait par passer
aujourd'hui il y a un million dans la
rue sauf qu'il y a plus de majorité et
par conséquent Elizabeth borne est
obligé de composer je suis pas dans je
suis pas à sa place je suis incapable de
juger quelles sont les quelle est la
ligne qui est susceptible de faire
passer la retraite 149-3 mais
même en faisant toutes les concessions
possibles parce que les syndicats parce
que les problèmes internes à LR etc font
que il y a une partie des données
qu'elle ne contrôle pas elle-même par
conséquent c'est compliqué je suis pas
du tout quels je suis pas prophète je
sais pas du tout ce que ça va donner
mais
j'aimerais pas être à sa place et le
49-3 Claude malgré ce serait la pire des
solutions pour faire passer ce texte je
pense que politiquement ce ne serait pas
ça ne serait pas favorable maintenant
depuis elle a fait quelques 49,3 depuis
le début à chaque fois qu'on fait à 49-3
tout le monde monte sur ses grands
chevaux et puis le lendemain on passe à
autre chose alors pour moi
uniquement sur deux têtes sur les textes
budgétaires oui enfin il y a eu
plusieurs
49-3 euh
plus de 49 fois bon je pense qu'elle est
politiquement quand vous faites une
réforme bien entendu il vaut mieux
qu'elle passe avec une majorité
maintenant vous avez des institutions de
58 je fais pas partie de ceux qui disent
le 43 est une catastrophe
anti-démocratique ou alors c'est la
cinquième République et une constitution
antidémocratique je considère qu'elle ne
l'est pas elle donne beaucoup de pouvoir
à l'exécutif mais rappelons-nous la
Quatrième République donc pour moi le
49-3
ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas le l'horreur absolue elle
fait partie des institutions ces
modifications et les affaires pourtant
de la main pour faire un pas vers les
républicains sauf qu'hier certains
républicains ont répondu Aurélien
Pradier parle de tromperie Xavier
Bertrand de Raiponce en trompe l'oeil
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
je vais pas faire je vais pas faire le
ménage chez les républiques je vais pas
leur dire je vais pas leur dire je les
aime bien c'est une famille à laquelle
j'ai appartenu mais enfin c'est une
famille qui n'a plus rien à voir avec
avec ce qu'il était
aujourd'hui non seulement elle a perdu
le comment dire
un trait pour le public il suffit de
voir le résultat des
de la présidentielle et les législatives
mais elle continue elle continue elle
continue à se déchirer et surtout
surtout quand je vois des pradés ou
d'autres
[Musique]
cette famille apparaît comme prête en
tout cas certains dans cette famille
apparaît comme prêt à renier
exactement le programme le programme de
LR le programme de Pécresse était
beaucoup plus loin donc cette réforme
que celui d'Élisabeth borne et
aujourd'hui on donne l'impression il
donne l'impression
qui que cette réforme n'est pas assez
social ni donne l'impression d'en
rajouter personne n'y comprend
moi je ne les comprends pas je ne ou
plutôt je les comprends trop
ils sont en train de régler les quand
même interne à LR sur le dos de la
réforme des retraites bon ils peuvent
continuer à le faire mais je ne suis pas
sûr du tout du tout que ça leur porte je
crois d'ailleurs qu'au Sénat on a
l'impression que c'est beaucoup plus
raisonné qui a une possibilité d'accord
et qu'on n'est pas dans l'assurance cher
avec des luttes de clan voilà une
question une question auvergnat
président de la Région votre région
Laurent Wauquiez des très proches autour
de lui de votre emploi pour cette loi
vous pensez que ça relève de c'est la
même analyse que vous faites
vous êtes sûr enfin je connais je sais
pas le j'ai pas entendu vos pieds
s'exprimer là-dessus je pense que la loi
définitive c'est n'est pas n'est pas
encore voté je pense que les discussions
vont continuer on commence juste
aujourd'hui l'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale donc si Laurent Wauquiez ne
veut pas voter cet enfant bah il ne la
voit pas
moi-même
je écoutais
on a quand même l'impression que
Éric Ciotti a été élu président de l'air
en attendant qu'il soutiendrait vos
pieds dans les années qui viennent et
pour la présidentielle Ciotti négocier
lui-même
et semble à titre personnel être parvenu
à un accord avec la première ministre il
est contesté à l'intérieur qui si en
plus il est contesté par celui
qu'il a soutenu alors c'est encore plus
compréhensible que tout le reste dans
votre groupe il y a des doutes où tout
le monde la votera oh je crois que tout
le monde la votera je peux pas vous
garantir je suis pas dans la tête
on fait des réunions on fait des
réunions de groupe régulièrement
je crois pas je crois pas au groupe
alors même si chez vous il y a pas que
des des sénateurs horizons mais au
groupe horizon à l'Assemblée nationale
il y a des sénateurs qui se posent des
questions des députés pardon qui se
posent des questions
nous sommes les indépendants et les gens
votent comme ils veulent mais que ce que
je retiens des réunions de groupe c'est
que très majoritairement est
probablement unanimement mais je n'en
sais rien nous voterons cette réforme
elle est non seulement elle est
indispensable mais on en parlait tout à
l'heure en commençant mais petit à petit
on est en train de la détricoter et par
conséquent le jour où la réforme coûtera
plus cher que ce qu'elle économisera
elle n'aura plus de chance
il ne faut plus toucher maintenant je ne
sais pas je
[Musique]
je suis pas à sa place elle est dans une
situation extrêmement extrêmement
difficile
qu'il y a aussi les entreprises moi je
suis je pense que les charges qui pèsent
sur les entreprises françaises et qui
ont expliquent une partie de la
désindustrialisation du pays depuis 30
40 ans etc
sont quelque chose d'ailleurs avec la
suppression ou la baisse des impôts de
production on rejoint petit à petit la
moyenne européenne petit à petit et on
est encore loin derrière donc c'est à
mon avis pas aujourd'hui sur les
entreprises que doit se faire l'accord
sur cette réforme
sur l'emploi des seniors bien sûr qu'il
y a un problème sur l'emploi du seniors
mais je pense que comme d'habitude dans
ce pays il faudrait résoudre les
problèmes par les discussions entre les
partenaires sociaux plutôt que par les
sanctions envers les uns ou un réseau ce
qui me paraît quand même
étonnant c'est qu'on n'arrive pas qu'il
faille une fois sur deux lorsqu'il y a
des des
ou des non d'accord d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement intervienne parce que les
partenaires sociaux n'ont pas réussi à
se mettre peut-être qu'un jour ou
l'autre on finira par y arriver comme
dans la plupart des pays d'Europe en
tout cas d'Europe du Nord
de retraite des parlementaires est-ce
que pour vous il faut le supprimer alors
c'est très c'est très particulier parce
que d'abord le retrait des parlementaire
les deux régimes sont complètement
différents
deuxièmement
ma position c'est que non seulement il
faudrait pas le suivant mais il faudrait
que tous les que le système de retraite
souhaite aligné sur celui des
parlementaire c'est-à-dire que je crois
pas qu'il faille prendre l'exemple d'un
système de retraite qui marche je prends
par exemple celle du Sénat c'est un
régime de retraite qui n'a rien à voir
avec le régime par répartition c'est une
capitalisation collective comme dans les
pays d'Europe du Nord tout le monde sait
tout le monde s'aperçoit tout le monde
le sait que le système du Sénat marche
très bien c'est ce qu'on lui d'habitude
évidemment comme comme on est en France
comme ça marche très bien il faut il
faut le
le démoli mais moi ça soit clair il y a
pas d'argent public et c'est un système
qui n'est pas difficile
prenons l'exemple de ces retraites de
cette retraite du Sénat parce que si
toutes les retraites étaient comme celle
du Genas c'est-à-dire un mix de retraite
par répartition et de capitalisation
politique mais le mot cabinalisation
c'est à cette un tabou c'est une injure
si nous faisions ce système qui est le
système des pays d'Europe du Nord et qui
marche très bien ça rentre dans le débat
il y en a qui disent il faudrait
instaurer une part de capitalisation et
pas faire uniquement régime par
répartition c'est aussi votre avis j'ai
entendu 2019
bien entendu c'est c'est le retrait par
exemple par mix répartition
capitalisation des Pays-Bas amène en
moyenne dans les dernières années 5,6%
d'augmentation par an parce que ce et et
il permet de résoudre ce problème
insoluble qui est celui de la baisse
progressive du nombre de cotisants par
rapport au nombre de retraités qui est
qui condamne le système de répartition à
terme et par conséquent il va bien il
faudra y passer mais là aussi ça fait
partie des interdits des des tabous
français si vous prononcez le mode
capitalisation même capitalisation
collective ça ne passe pas mais c'est ça
l'avenir pour ne plus avoir ce problème
entre le nombre de cotisants et le
nombre de retraités contre Charles de
Courson qui a remis sur la table ce
sujet du régime parlementaire
régime de retraite vous savez
régulièrement
de Courson
fait ça depuis longtemps et d'ailleurs
il l'a fait pour leur pour ce qui
concerne l'Assemblée nationale et et il
a fait changer ce système pour
l'Assemblée nationale donc Charles de
Gauchon tous les ans lors de tous les
débats budgétaires à un certain nombre
d'amendements il les représentent
infatigablement et de temps en temps il
y en a un qui passe mais je suis pas
fâché je dis simplement que c'est pas
parce que il y a un système marche bien
qu'il faut le en l'air c'est
parce qu'il marche bien qu'il faut s'en
inspirer il faut s'en inspirer et qu'il
faut faire et qu'il faut l'étendre à
tout le monde et on le disait le débat
souvent que cet après-midi à l'Assemblée
avec 18000 amendements déposés rien que
pour la nuque comment vous qualifiez
leur stratégie
une stratégie d'obstruction
qui risque de se d'être une stratégie
d'arroseur arrosée
d'abord d'abord depuis le début depuis
le mois de juin la nuque c'est les
termes même de Madame Tondelier de
l'écolo il transforme l'Assemblée
nationale en ZAD bon je pense que déjà
depuis le mois de juin ils se sont fait
sentiraient beaucoup de balles dans le
pied parce que les gens ont vraiment
ras-le-bol de cette de ces situations et
ça ne bénéficie qu'à une personne Madame
Le Pen qui est en train de tirer les
marrons du feu qu'il continue à se
discréditer moi ça ne et à faire
d'assuenchère ça me gênement national
oui elle fait du jeu du rassemblement
national elle est antidémocratique elle
n'apparaît de jour en jour et surtout
elle se tire elle-même une balle dans le
pied et petit à petit je pense que elle
est en train de commencer sa descente
aux enfers qu'elle aurait dû commencer
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps parce que
c'est un parti c'est même pas un parti
c'est c'est une secte puisqu'il y a pas
de pas de mouvement il n'y a pas de vote
mais vous mettez tout le monde dans le
même sac pardon ou c'est uniquement la
France insoumise essentiellement
excusez-moi
l'essentiel des amendements c'est la
France insoumise sur des sur les 18 donc
donc effectivement c'était peut-être un
raccourci je parle je parle les filles
mais ça va être là aujourd'hui puisque
vous savez très bien qu'il y a un temps
limité pour le réforme et par conséquent
plus il y a des rendements plus on
arrivera pas à l'article 7 qui est
l'article qui veut étudier qui est
l'article sur les tournages et par
conséquent il
ils vont s'apercevoir qu'un beau jour on
va dire maintenant on arrête puisque
c'est terminé et non seulement on va pas
garder le texte tel qu'il sera mais on
va reprendre le texte initial du
gouvernement pour le transférer
qui a mis un temps limité sur ce texte
nous on aurait voulu beaucoup plus de
temps
mais on est dans cette situation et par
conséquent ils vont empêcher leur 18000
abandon ne seront pas examinés le texte
va être transmis tel quel au Sénat qui
vont arriver
à l'effet inverse ce qu'ils veulent
après tout si c'est ce qu'ils veulent
moi ça m'est égal mais c'est une
solution qui me paraît simplement
déclammatoire pour pouvoir dire une fois
de plus on
permet pas le débat démocratique et qui
n'a absolument aucune volonté de faire
aboutir un certain nombre d'amendements
un dernier mot sur l'examen de ce texte
c'est Olivier du sott qui porte cette
réforme il est soupçonné de favoritisme
par le parquet national financier dans
une affaire de marché public datant de
2009 lorsqu'il était maire d'Annonay
est-ce que c'est un ministre affaibli
qui va porter ce projet de loi
probablement dans les dans le système
actuel où on condamne avant d'avoir
avant que les juges ne défaient n'est
jamais bon pour un homme politique de
soumis ce genre de mais j'ai vu
tellement
je sais comment ça va se finir je pense
savoir comment ça va finir j'ai vu
tellement de politique se faire
massacrer il y a des exemples et je
regardais Fabius sur la perdition
contaminé dans laquelle il avait
vraiment rien à voir et dans lequel il
n'est pas pris du tout de décision qui
ont conduit à ce scandale salut et qui a
été à la fin
lavé de de toutes les accusations et on
pourra en voir détails d'État et ça se
termine comme ça mais entre temps vous
avez alors je pense pas que pour du Soi
plus le sujet soit de cette ampleur et
que ça voilà mais c'est
je ne peux pas non plus ne pas me poser
la question comment comment ça se fait
qu'on annonce ça que ça arrive
le jour où
je ne sais pas si c'est un hasard je
m'interroge je me dis c'est quand même
si c'est un hasard c'est un drôle de
hasard
votre initiative une proposition de
résolution invitant de Sénat affirmer
son soutien à l'Ukraine c'était
nécessaire vous espérez l'unanimité
autour de ce texte alors d'une part je
pense que c'était nécessaire parce que
le Sénat était une des dernières
chambres en Europe qui n'avaient pas
pris cette résolution le Sénat a fait
beaucoup de choses Gérard Larcher
est-elle et lui-même en Ukraine moi même
j'y suis allé avec un certain nombre
d’autres d'amis sénateurs et
Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat
aussi invité le président de la Rada
ukrainienne déjà une première fois et
puis une deuxième les parlements la
plupart des parlements européens ont
pris des résolutions le Parlement
européen lui-même a pris une notion
extrêmement ferme
l'Assemblée nationale l'a fait il y a 15
jours ou trois semaines et par
conséquent il me paraissait nécessaire
effectivement comme vous dites que le
Sénat marque lui-même par une résolution
et pas seulement par des acteurs
individuels même si c'est de son
président que le Sénat marque son
soutien et surtout sa condamnation la
volonté de juger les crimes de guerre et
la volonté de réaffirmer parce que c'est
ça qui compte aujourd'hui le soutien et
le soutien jusqu'à la victoire comme le
disait le président de la République
lors de ses vœux à l'Ukraine vous le
disiez le président de la Rada était
devant vous devant les sénateurs un
mercredi dernier il a demandé que la
France soit la première nation à livrer
à l'Ukraine des avions modernes
qu'est-ce qu'il faut lui répondre moi je
suis à titre personnel pour que on donne
à l'Ukraine on peut pas dire à l'Ukraine
à côté nous vous soutiendrons jusqu'à la
victoire finale c'est bien les termes du
président de la République et en même
temps ne pas lui en donner les moyens
donc je suis pour qu'on donne à
l'Ukraine tous les moyens nécessaires je
connais y compris les avions je
comprends le le discours habituel de la
part des réalistes entre guillemets
comme il se comme il se nomme c'est de
dire il y a des lignes fonctionne pas
franchir qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
lignes rouges ces Poutine qui les traces
donc si nous acceptons les lignes rouges
ça veut dire que et si nous disons il
faut pas d'escalade ça veut dire qu'on
laisse aboutir le monopole de l'escalade
et bien entendu c'est d'abord c'est
inacceptable parce que c'est pas comme
ça que les Ukrainiens vont gagner et
deuxièmement
[Musique]
les menaces de Poutine on le voit depuis
le début ne signifient rien depuis le
début c'est la dixième fois qu'on
franchit des lignes rouges c'est la
dixième fois qu'il a dit qu'il dit vous
allez voir ça va être l'Apocalypse et il
ne se passe rien pourquoi il se passe
rien parce qu'il est au maximum parce
que son armée est en déroute sur
un quartier va Carson parce qu'elle
arrive à avoir grappiller un village par
ci par là et donc elle est elle est
rangée par la corruption elle a des
commandants incompétents elle a des
soldats qui ne veulent pas aller se
battre et par conséquent il donne une
situation très très difficile pour ne
serait-ce que tenir ses lignes et par
conséquent par définition il lui est
impassé impossible d'aller plus loin la
seule façon d'aller plus loin et ça
c'est le deuxième argument qu'on entend
c'est toujours l'argument pour faire
peur c'est l'arme nucléaire alors l'arme
nucléaire depuis la réunion de sa marque
avec Jing ping emoji nous savons que
Poutine a été humilié qu'il a été mis au
piqué par ses principaux alliés et qu'on
lui qui lui ont dit il n'est pas
question pas question que vous utilisez
un jour nucléaire donc on sait que cette
menace est une menace que c'est un
disque rayé depuis le début et par
conséquent oui il faut donner à
l'Ukraine tous les moyens et par
l'Ukraine tous les moyens pour gagner il
fallait jusqu'à leur donner des avions
la France n'a toujours pas donné de
position claire ne serait-ce que sur les
chars Leclerc c'est un problème pour
vous vous le regrettez
je vais pas je pense qu'il ne faut pas
dans ce par rapport à Poutine il faut
pas se diviser donc je vais pas
critiquer la France l'Allemagne etc oui
il est clair que la France et
l'Allemagne depuis le début ce conflit
ne sont pas sur la même position que les
pays d'Europe de l'Est et il est clair
que ma position est beaucoup plus proche
de celle des pays d'Europe de l'Est que
de celle des
paysans d'Europe de l'Ouest parce que
les pays d'Europe de l'Est ils ont vécu
ça pendant 50 ans ils savent ce que
c'est impérialisme que l'impérialisme
russe l'impérialisme soviétique avant et
l'impérialisme russe aujourd'hui donc je
crois qu'il faut les qu'il faut les
écouter
maintenant je comprends que des
décisions comme les chars comme les
avions etc sous doivent être prises en
accord et que c'est quand il vaut mieux
discuter parfois perdre du temps mais
finir et c'est ce qu'on a réussi à faire
jusqu'à présent à ce que l'Europe soit
unique elle soit unie avec ses alliés
avec les États-Unis et les autres et
plutôt que de prendre des initiatives
qui risqueraient de diviser le front
voilà donc je comprends les difficultés
à prendre des décisions petit à petit
moi ce que la seule chose c'est de quand
je vois les différentes lignes rouges
qu'on a franchi si on avait franchi
toutes ces lignes rouges dès le début et
qu'on est livré dès le début l'armement
qu'on est en train de livrer aujourd'hui
non seulement les Ukrainiens auraient
pris le Dombasle aurait repris le
quartier avec Carson mais au moment de
la déroute russe serait progresser déjà
depuis longtemps dans le Dombasle
de proposition de résolution que vous
avez déposée pour la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur le
fonctionnement du réseau social Tik Tok
ce réseau social chinois on le rappelle
vous inquiète plus particulièrement que
oui alors je dirais tous les réseaux
sociaux moi je les qualifie de réseau en
tisociaux
il m'inquiète parce que c'est des pour
moi une bonne partie de ces réseaux
c'est une entreprise de desserts des
adolescents et même des adultes
d'ailleurs
ceux avec des modalités différentes
certains de ces réseaux sociaux peuvent
avoir une utilité peuvent avoir un
intérêt mais une bonne partie de ce qui
est dedans c'est tout simplement en
avant d'ailleurs
Emmanuel Macron lui-même disait qu'en ce
qui concernait Tik Tok il a utilisé les
mots de naïveté confondante c'est une
litote parce que voilà ça veut bien dire
ce que ça veut dire un président de la
République peut pas utiliser n'importe
quel mot moi je peux me permettre je
vous dis c'est des entreprises de
déserts ça c'est déjà
très ennuyeux mais le problème qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est que Tik Tok est
accusé
aux États-Unis et dans un certain nombre
de pays européens de choses beaucoup
plus graves est accusée de violation du
système de données chef de protection
des données européennes et ça c'est
important et accusé d'espionnage et
d'avoir notamment
livret un certain nombre de données sur
beaucoup de journalistes ce qui devrait
ici
nous faire réfléchir donc il y a un
certain nombre de d'accusation je ne dis
pas de de preuve il y a un certain
nombre d'accusation graves concernant ce
réseau sans compter que toute entreprise
chinoise vous le savez toute entreprise
chinoise quelle qu'elle soit un réseau
social ou un est obligé de collaborer
avec les systèmes de renseignement
chinois c'est la loi chinoise qui les y
oblige donc rien que cela il y a déjà un
problème donc comme vous le voyez il y a
beaucoup d'accusations qui sont portées
et par conséquent ça me paraît tout à
fait logique tout à fait nécessaire que
le Sénat mène une commission d'enquête
là-dessus je ne sais pas si elle aura
lieu puisque c'est la conférence du
président qui doit en décider j'espère
que qu'elle aura lieu en tout cas je
l'ai proposé merci Claude manuré merci
beaucoup